bonsoir modèle blanchemaison d'après
donc les statistiques publiées on l'a vu
par l'association protestante
les chiffres sont très inquiétants ne va
pas les redire une situation contraire
au droit international pourtant oui bien
sûr c'est cette situation persécution et
est contraire au droit international
mais leurs internationaux n'est pas
respecter ce droit international c'est
d'abord la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme des nations unies qui
a été signé à paris précisément en 1948
au palais de chaillot et les 193 états
membres de l'onu doivent respecter cette
convention qui s'inspire d'ailleurs de
la droite elle convention de la
lointaine déclarations françaises et
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
en tout cas la liberté de conscience et
la liberté de religion est garanti par
l'onu est ainsi que d'ailleurs le
changement de religion et la conversion
dont et la possibilité de pratiquer sa
religion
alors ceci n'est pas véritablement
respecter par les états parce qu'il ya
des états qui eux mêmes ne respecte pas
d'autres qui laissent faire des groupes
extrémistes ou qui les encourage et puis
d'autres qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'empêcher les dix groupes extrémistes
d'agir
donc pour toutes ces raisons
effectivement les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes et la situation précaire des
chrétiens d'orient et notamment souvent
évoquée depuis les guerres en irak et en
syrie
vous parlez des étapes de blanchemaison
justement qu'elle joue t-il quel rôle
pardon joue-t-il fasseur aux pratiques
religieuses
alors tous les états essaient
d'organiser des relations avec les
pratiques religieuses mais de façon
évidemment différente alors le plus
simple c'est la corée du nord puisque
toute pratique religieuse y est
interdite sauf peut-être la vénération
des trois kim mais ça ce n'est pas
vraiment une pratique
2 en chine c'est différent le parti
communiste chinois s'est toujours méfié
les bouddhistes s'est toujours méfié
aussi des chrétiens qu'ils soient
catholiques protestants ou évangélistes
mais il ya quelque temps le pouvoir le
pouvoir de pékin a accepté de négocier
un accord avec le vatican qui permet de
supprimer la distinction entre l'église
officielle d'obédience communiste et
l'église souterraine fidèles au vatican
donc maintenant il n'y a plus qu'une
seule église catholique et le vatican
s'est engagé à consulter les autorités
chinoises avant de nommer deux nouveaux
évêques
ceci fait débat d'ailleurs dans la dans
la dans le monde catholique et aussi
chez les évangélistes qui naturellement
ne sont pas n'ont rien à voir avec cet
accord et des églises sont d'ailleurs
toujours fermés ou en voir en voie de
l'être en chine
et puis il ya la situation particulière
de l'arabie saoudite où il n'y a pas de
constitution
mais la religion musulmane est la seule
qui soit à bize c'est beaucoup c'est en
effet un régime donc musulman république
islamiste
autres républiques islamistes l'iran
d'une autre branche de l'islam
si et en iran eh bien on admet qu'il ya
plusieurs religions et l'iran notamment
admis les pratiques religieuses
anciennes comme celles des des chrétiens
d'orient qui sont caldera ou qui sont
d'origine
cyriac et qui ne cherchent pas à
convertir les musulmans qui par
conséquent n'exerce aucun prosélytisme
il existe aussi pas beaucoup mais
quelques quelques catholiques en iran et
avec six évêques qui naturellement n'ont
pas donc pas la vie non pas la vie très
facile on peut continuer évidemment à
prendre d'autres exemples comme
le pakistan l'état islamique ou là là
lol le blasphème étudie par la loi et où
les gens qui ne sont qui sont qui ne
sont pas musulmans
on éprouve beaucoup de difficultés pour
les actes d'état civil pour entrer dans
la fonction publique
ok pour diverses choses par conséquent
il ya des discriminations juridique à
l'égard des chrétiens au pakistan et des
condamnations au titre de cette loi sur
le sur le blasphème
en inde c'est un peu différent puisque
le gouvernement enfin la constitution
plus exactement et laïque et que toutes
les religions sont 100 sur le même plan
en principe mais évidemment 80% d d d d
habitants et en inde ou de religion
hindoue et bien le gouvernement actuel
cet agrément nationaliste veut favoriser
les hindous en organisant l'identité
indienne autour de l'hindouisme ce qui
arrive ce qui revient à discriminer les
musulmans et aussi d'une certaine
manière les chrétiens alors le panorama
que vous faites n'est guère réjouissant
comment expliquer que l'intolérance
progressed ans en 2021 elle progresse
parce que les gouvernements
certains gouvernements en tout cas
utilisent la religion l'instrumentalise
et c'est le cas souvent de gouvernement
nationaliste autoritaire à tendances
autoritaires qui trouve pratique
d'utiliser la religion dominante pour
affirmer leur point de vue mais
également pour peut-être attirer
l'attention sur autre chose que les
difficultés que les békés sociale du
pays il ya aussi évidemment la
concurrence entre divers branche de
l'islam entre les chiites et les
sunnites entre par conséquent l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite
et cette concurrence amen
à accepter des pratiques
discriminatoires qui sont contraires au
droit au droit public international
mais évidemment les peut pas rester sans
réagir et les opinions publiques
réagissent si l'on prend par exemple
l'exemple de pakistan où une jeune femme
avait été condamnée par un tribunal pour
blasphème
finalement sous la pression de divers
pays d'un grand notre majorité de pays
occidentaux et bien la cour suprême a
fini par libérer cette jeune femme elle
a malheureusement dû s'exiler elle est
exilé au canada mais est bien entendu
les manifestations réclamant son
exécution continue dans les pays ce sont
des groupes extrémistes qui continuent
de manifester contraire mais les
gouvernements sont pas indifférents à
l'opinion internationale et par
conséquent le rapport qui a été publié
hier aura bien entendu une certaine
influence parce que les gouvernements
n'ont pas envie d'être mis au ban des
nations
ils ont accepté des obligations au titre
des nations unies et doivent les
respecter mais il y aura encore beaucoup
de difficultés sur ce plan et sans doute
des persécutions
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse sur ce
sujet